In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for June 25th, on which we commemorate, the Holy
martyr, Febronia, on the 25th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Virgin
and martyr, Febronia.
During the reign of Diocletian Anthemus, prefect of Rome, having fallen gravely ill, confided
his son, Lysimicus, to his brother Selenius.
Three days after Anthemus's death, the emperor summoned the young Lysimicus and told him
that he intended to make him prefect of Rome, on condition, however, that he give proof
of his fidelity by going to the east to persecute the Christians, as the rumor was circulating
that he had been drawn to their cause by his mother.
Lysimicus, being able to make no objection, set off with his uncle at the head of a strong
force, arriving in Palmyra on the borders of Syria and Mesopotamia, Selenius put a great
many Christians to death in the cruelest way, and thus acquired a reputation in the whole
of the east as a bloodthirsty tyrant.
Lysimicus, who had, in fact, profound sympathy for Christians, was greatly troubled by
this campaign, and suggested to his nephew Primos, who was commanding the detachment of soldiers
to let the Christians know they were coming so that they could hide.
In Nisebys there was a woman's monastery where 50 consecrated virgins engaged in the struggle
for virtue under the direction of the wise Brienne. Among her disciples, Fabronia stood
out. She was her very own niece, 20 years of age, who had been brought up in the monastery
from the age of two, and who was gifted with a radiant beauty enhanced by the grace of
her virtues. One day a pagan girl of high birth called Yeria arrived at the monastery
and insistently asked to speak with Fabronia. Her heart was so moved by her conversation
with a young nun that they spent the whole night keeping vigil, shedding floods of tears.
When she returned home, Yeria told about her visit to the monastery and begged her parents
to receive the good news. Shortly after this, as Salinas was preparing
to enter Nisebys, all the Christians, given prior warning by Primos, hid themselves in
the caves and the mountains. In the monastery, Brienne prepared her disciples to confront
death with courage for love of Christ, but some of the virgins using the argument that
even the bishop and the most influential Christians had fled asked to go and hide.
Fabronia exclaimed, by Christ the living God whose spouse I have become, I shall not for
all the world, leave this place. Brienne nevertheless left each of them to do as her conscience
dictated. And all the other nuns, having given way to natural weakness, she remained alone
with Fabronia and Tomé, trembling for the young Fabronia at the thought of the outrages
that the persecutors would not hesitate to inflict on her delicate beauty, she reminded her
of the admirable constancy, that a short time before, Saints Libia, Leonis and Yotropa,
had shown under torture. In the morning, Salinas ordered that all Christians
they found be thrown into prison and put to torture. Soldiers descended on the monastery,
shattering the doors and finding only three nuns, drew their swords on Brienne to make her
tell them where her other disciples were. But Fabronia fell at their feet, begging them to
kill her first, to spare her the sight of the death of her mother in Christ. Meanwhile, Primos
arrived at the monastery, drove away the soldiers, and learning that the other nuns had fled
advised Brienne and her companions to do the same. On his return to the Praetorium, he
told Lecymicus, he told Lecymicus that he had seen in the monastery, a virgin of incomparable
beauty, and suggested that he take her as his bride. But Lecymicus retorted that, having
been ordered by his mother not to ill treat the Christians, he had the more reason to keep
himself from insulting a virgin consecrated to God, but to do all he could to protect her.
The soldiers, having made their report to Salinas, vaunting Fabronia's beauty in their turn,
he sent them to seize the virgin and have her brought, without however, allowing her companions
to go with her, to may, however, manage to follow the escort in male garb. When they took
Fabronia into the amphitheater, where a large crowd had gathered, the magistrate, struck by
her charm, set aside his grounds for accusation to suggest she marry his nephew, Lecymicus,
with the promise that she would enjoy great glory in Rome.
With the saint replied with assurance that she was already promised to an immortal spouse,
who was awaiting her in his palace, and assured him that nothing would make her renounce
him. Salinas, in fury, ordered that she be exposed naked to public derision.
Having overcome the shame of our first parents and clothed herself in the new man, Fabronia
assured the tyrant that, being stripped, she was ready to do battle like an athlete
against the devil and his demons. Four men stretched her over a brazier that had been made
to burn more fiercely by throwing on oil, while four others thrashed her mercilessly in spite
of the crowd that was asking for pardon for the delicate girl.
Far from stopping, Salinas had her beaten the harder and the torturers left her half dead.
As soon as she came to herself, the saint showed her scorn for the idolaters and was given
over once more to the soldiers who lacerated her ribs. They then broke her teeth one by one,
and as she remained immovable, they cut off her breasts and burned her chest.
Yeria, who was present in the crowd, raised cries of indignation and took the saint's side.
She was immediately arrested, but fearing her high state and the people's reaction, Salinas
did not put her to torture, and to show how he scorned her protests, had them cut off both
Fabronia's hands and one foot. The saint offered her hands to the sword, but the executioner,
having to make three attempts to cut off her foot, inflicted such intolerable pain on her
that she put her other foot on the block, begging him to have done. He cut it off and she remained
in agony before the magistrate. He, wanting his dinner, ordered that she be beheaded.
On his return to the palace, Salinas was seized with madness and perished after banging his head
against a pillar. Lysimicus was left desolated after the death of the saint. He sent his soldiers to
gather her precious remains and take them to the monastery where Brianna and her nuns received them
with great lamentation. Then renouncing both fortune and career, he went to the monastery
followed by Primos and a large number of soldiers. After having received Holy Baptism, they became
monks. Angeria baptized together with her whole family became a nun in Brianna's monastery.
When her memory was celebrated every year after that, Fabronia appeared in the choir among the
sisters. However, if anyone tried to touch her or speak to her, she would immediately become
invisible. When the local bishop had a new church built in honor of the saint, he asked to translate
her relics, but when they drew near to the reliquary, an earthquake accompanied by claps of thunder
repulsed their impudence, showing Saint Fabronia's desire to remain in her monastery.
They were only able to take away one tooth, which once placed in the new church, worked many miracles.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us and save us.